after his defeat Napoleon bonapart was
exiled to welber by the Victorious
Coalition Powers as you'll know he came
back and after his second defeat he was
exiled yet again but this time further
away but given what he put the Coalition
allies through and the risk he posed by
still remaining alive why was Napoleon
only exiled instead of being permanently
dealt with so in 1814 the Coalition had
marched on Paris and the French Senate
declared Napoleon deposed Napoleon
wanted to keep fighting but his General
said no and demanded that he leave and
because Prussia Russia and Austria just
wanted the war to be over they agreed to
let Napoleon enter Exile on the
condition that he renounced the French
throne he eventually agreed and was then
allowed to leave for Elba this was much
to the annoyance of the British who
wanted to imprison him because they saw
his entire reign as illegitimate but as
you'll all know he returned to France a
year later upon his return he was given
an army and fought the Coalition again
before losing so why was it then that in
spite of the threat that Napoleon's
existence was why didn't the Allies 100%
guarantee that he wasn't going to be a
problem again well the great Powers
mostly wanted different things for
Napoleon the British were very much
against execution because its government
believed that the restored bbon dynasty
was fragile if Napoleon were to be given
a free trip to the afterlife there were
fears that those still loyal to him
would rise up and potentially plunge
France into a Civil War which would need
dealing with and Britain didn't feel
like it Austria and Russia were both
mixed there was a genuine desire for
vengeance but given that Napoleon's
Imperial coronation had been given the
blessing of the Pope the idea of ending
his life was seen as a step too far all
also both Nations had previously allied
with Napoleon and executing someone who
a few years prior was your ally wasn't a
good look and the Russians wanted to
keep him alive as a threat to the rest
of Europe whereas the prussians had no
such quarms of execution and its
generals were openly calling for
Napoleon's head bonapart escape from
Exile had solidified this position and
many prussians believed that Napoleon
was capable of returning from anywhere
except the grave the Prussian King
didn't share this opinion which is why
the cause for his head went nowhere of
course all of this squabbling was
irrelevant because Napoleon had cleverly
handed himself over to the British
Napoleon knew that they were going to be
the most lenient and he believed that he
would be allowed to live out the rest of
his days in the UK as a free man this
was obviously wrong but the British
weren't willing to hand him over for
execution and so he knew that at least
he'd live given his previous Escape
though Napoleon wasn't going to be given
anywhere to rule and so instead he was
exiled to St Helena here and he would
remain here under house arrest until his
death in 1821 I hope you enjoyed this
episode with a special thanks to my
patrons James Bizet Kelly moneymaker
Chappelle kitka Andy McGee Anthony
Becket Alex Schwin rodie Martin Udan
Wang AF Firefly Spencer lighfoot Marcus
Arna W and hockey Captain PG Marvin CAU
kimon Yun the mcer Gustav Swan Maggie
Paskowski calling Dr Howard Dr Fine Dr
Howard spinning three plates copper tone
shenin words about books podcast Ked
Alder Wood Winston kwood Jim Stromberg
Charles I and Miss is it